it's true it's
it's no extra
uh meaning to win a championship no
matter who you playing again it's
already hard enough to even reach the
finals
um to be in this position so
if you're able to become
victorious out of the finals it doesn't
matter who it's against um
you know you just
i'm just happy that i'm here with
opportunity um you know to represent uh
not only myself but represent our fans
our fan base
our organization uh my teammates our
coaching staff
our training staff and so many others
that represent this organization uh to
the most respect
so he said absolutely not
and as usual lebron said all the right
things
right but you know what man we're taught
to be skeptical and you know when they
say one thing they really mean another
and
i i actually believe him
i believe him you know wow i'm not going
to lie training day i don't believe you
i don't believe you know i actually
believe him i actually do believe him
because i feel like
the reason and i know it ended badly but
badly for whom exactly
you know what i mean like it's not like
the heat this isn't a traditional
reunion it's not like that he traded
lebron it's not like that he released
lebron or cut lebron it's not like they
knew that lebron was done finished
you know
and
you know put a curse on him until you do
right by us or whatever it's like look
he decided to go home to cleveland
the people who were in their feelings
about that move
were the heat so
i'm sure the heat would love
to ruin lebron's coronation or you know
to stop him from getting a fourth
championship
but i don't i think lebron at this point
in his career and his life is on such a
higher plane of thought such a higher
he's got his purpose and his motivation
and his drive uh is is much
more sophisticated and much
greater much more significant
than uh the storylines that we could
think of you know i don't think he has
anything to prove to the heat that you
know i i gotta stop pat riley look i
think he appreciates he went on to talk
about pat riley being in the finals and
part of four decades i believe it is
um right you know at various levels i
think he appreciated what riley and spo
did for him to help make him the person
and the player and the champion that he
is i'm more than sure some of his habits
and some of his approach stems from his
time as part of the miami culture he
took a lot of miami culture what he
learned there
brought it to cleveland
delivered his defining moment to this
point and now i went to la and that
organization needed a culture change and
he's taught them how to win or he's
elevated them back to the finals and so
i do believe him that the last thing on
his mind is
revenge or motivation of proving a point
to pat riley and eric spoelstra i think
at this point
he's just more about
uh
trying to walk away with as many titles
as he as he can and and trying to add to
his neck legacy notice not chase kobe
honor kobe not chase kobe
carry on michael jordan's legacy not
match it or surpass it i think as we
talked about earlier this week he's
doing his own thing and i don't think
just means i gotta get this championship
because this is why i play not for
somebody else's storyline
yeah mike i think you're right well if
you say it doesn't matter to him right
now if you say right now i agree
he's probably not thinking about it now
but it's something
to look back on because if you think
about it they win a championship against
miami heat
this is what it will mean it will mean
that when he left cleveland remember uh
that that juvenile letter that dan
gilbert put out this self-proclaimed
king
rest sleep sleep well cleveland rest
assured that your cavaliers will win
before this self-proclaimed king does
well wrong wrong uh that didn't happen
so he was able to
leave cleveland
dan gilbert is like talking about him up
and down just cussing him out
then he goes back he wins in miami
so
one dan gilbert uh what's your that
curse
that color purple curse that you try to
put on me that michael smith just did
that didn't work
he goes back to cleveland
dan gilbert you got to be rooting for me
now
you got to be rooting for me i'm going
to win in cleveland on my terms comes
back and he wins
and when he left miami pat riley he
didn't quite go gilbert
well he was a little whiny
he was a little salty little
little pet it was patty it was fatty and
on top of everything i don't remember
what he remember exactly what he said
not to put you on the spot do you know
what he said
pretty much he was saying look hey you
go through it you go through tough times
you go through adversity this is the
time this is the time really to stay you
know these
pretty much it was like the old man
these kids these days whenever they run
into any adversity they run away and on
top of that i don't know if you remember
it not only was pat riley
like get off of my lawn doing the old
man thing and yelling
he also broke the news he wasn't
supposed to that lebron's wife savannah
was pregnant
do you remember this
yeah yeah and there were a lot of
stories that came out now that you
mentioned it there were some stories
that came out i'm not saying necessarily
pat riley was a source but there were a
lot of stories about
by lebron's tenure in miami that were
less than flattering about just how he
conducted himself and and some of the
clashes the culture clashes i i do i do
recall that yeah but go ahead go ahead
yeah so i think all right so you leave
you leave miami and you go off and do
your own thing you win a championship
but wouldn't it be something to go back
and then win against miami so all the
teams that i played for
i made them better when i left
the executives had some things to say
but in the end
i prevail
so
it may not be there's a three it may not
be on his mind
that may not be on his mind right now
but i think he will but i i do want to
say this about lebron you know we were
talking the other day
about you know the goats and
you know
lebron versus jordan and
somebody said to you you know why didn't
we include kobe i don't
i don't think of kobe that way i don't
think kobe is in the conversation as the
greatest player of all time he is an
all-time great he is a top 10 player
he's a number two shooting guard by far
that's it number two
nobody is close
so you know maybe dwayne wade is three
but kobe's two jordans won
and shooting guards but i don't think of
him as the greatest player of all time
but
i say that now i say that now when i
look at
you call you ask me who my all-time
great is all right today let's say today
it's jordan
i can't be swayed though my i'm not one
of those people
who says i'm not gonna change my mind
okay my mind my mind can change and i
look at i look at what lebron is doing
right now
i think it's i think it's incredible
despite the finals record that is that
got more losses than wins
the min the mental toughness the ability
to carry
multiple teams to championship stages
uh the
elite level that he's playing at at the
age of 35. there are a lot of things
where i look at him and say all right
right now do i have him the best of all
time no
but once upon a time is he is he
definitely your number two is he right
is he is he after jordan
i always say i say he's in in the in
that five he's like somewhere from like
one you know one to four let's say he's
not five one to four
but once upon a time
i i vowed hey nobody's better than joe
montana
i say that no no i've never put another
quarterback over joe montana and the
same standard that you have knocked
around appropriately so that he's 4-0 in
super bowls
and he's never thrown a super bowl
interception
but that's not it once you start looking
at a career it's kind of hard to ignore
what you're seeing
and so
i'm not putting them over jordan now but
i might next week in a week
i was about to say in a week yeah so if
if he gets number four whether
i mean there's three teams but it's
three franchises but let's say four
teams so if he gets
um
if he gets excused if he gets a fourth
championship with a third team i beg
your pardon a third team
that to you would change your mind
but
by that but by that rationale all right
but what if he does what he's done in
the past okay i saw like i sound like uh
events of vegan pulp fiction but by that
rationale
yeah you know
a dog would cease to be a filthy animal
if you
don't know but um
if the if the what if he's brilliant
what if he does what he's done in the
past believe against the warriors in one
or two series and averages like a
triple-double for the series and leads
both teams and scoring rebound assists
he does his lebron thing
what if he's what if he does that
but the heat
win the series because lebron doesn't
have
turns out the support and cast you know
ain't up to it
how will that affect how you view lebron
historically
i don't know
i don't know i mean that's a that's a
really good question
um
because it's difficult now isn't it like
before before lebron 1-1 there was like
this whole cottage industry of lebron
haters because he hadn't won
so you could talk about oh he doesn't
have that he didn't have that extra
thing he didn't have this he's a
brilliant talent but he doesn't know how
to win so he wins the first one and wins
the second one and so that starts to go
away a little bit back to back
now that he's won a third
could he have a great series averaging a
triple-double as you say still lose the
series but go up in stature i guess
that's possible but i'm looking at it i
don't think that's going to happen but
it doesn't go down if they lose it
doesn't go down for you doesn't go down
but i haven't considered it because i
don't think it's going to happen i think
he's going to win yeah they're going to
win and i think they're going to win
quite easily
well that's why
i think it's going to be a five game i
think it's gonna be a five game series
all right
but the reason why that's why what
well that's why i don't do championships
um
i'm not saying they don't count
of course they do that's why they play
but in team sports i try to
evaluate all-time greats and rank them
or mount rushmore or whatever you want
to call it i have my go discussions i
try to exclude championships and
certainly records in finals
you know the 6-0
that's the only argument i need sean i
just
i mean because all right he goes he wins
six times in six trips to the finals
without playing the game
without playing a game okay but i mean
is that it's not playing the game that's
good i think that's a great stat but but
that's but that's a that's his that's a
team accomplishment i guess let me just
go across sports for a second okay so
magic goes nine times
and wins five
so where do you balance six times that
you made it
but other times you didn't at all
you went all six
and i'm a jordan guy
versus going nine times and winning five
you went nine times so for lebron he's
three if he's three and six now if he's
three and seven or or or four and six
well
case may be right at the end of this
series whatever he is it's like he went
10 times that's why i gave him his
flowers earlier this week
i want to give him his flowers now
because for me
it i don't think
i don't think
it's gonna move the needle whatever he
does this week for me because i
recognize his greatness independent of
what his team ends up accomplishing
okay but see this is what you it this is
why you can't you can't dismiss i agree
with you you can't make it i'm just
missing i'm not dismissing i'm not
dismissing championships
you can't just say
boom it's not your drop mic oh 6-0 in
the discussion yeah it shouldn't be that
yeah
right
but it's not an insignificant thing
either because i'm gonna i'm gonna
eliminate all the other sports just very
quickly
baseball 25 guys done
25 guys and especially if you're not a
pitcher so if we we don't we don't say
about a center fielder or right fielder
he has won x amount of championships
well yeah he's a right fielder and who
knows they got a bad bullpen
some guys don't get that love though
some guys jeter gets that kind of like
cheaters
because jeter gets that kind of love for
reigning that's his new york that's just
a yankee yeah you know yeah that's just
that's just how they roll anyway but in
baseball it's it's difficult just to
focus on one guy one of 25 put that
aside even in hockey if you are a great
talent in hockey in a 60 minute game the
best the best players are playing what
24 25 minutes is a ton in hockey and you
got you got 20 guys move that aside
football
even more interdependent it's harder but
it doesn't stop you from doing it with
quarterbacks though doesn't stop from
doing a quarterback so you and i both
know it you mentioned joe montana it was
four what was his i do i know i don't
really exactly brady you know that's the
one i want to focus on i said across
sports i don't know just trying to
thought but brady got six super bowls in
his what lost three he lost three three
yeah okay so he's lost three one six
the ones he lost
easily could have won
okay
all three one all three of them
the ones he won
easily could have lost could have lost
half of five of them
yeah whatever it is you know what i mean
i mean the first three were all atlanta
seattle right i mean come on you know
malcolm butler gave him one kyle
shanahan and the falcons game they gave
him another i mean they didn't give it
to him but you understand no no no they
did they're cursed they're cursed but
there's a curse again you know color
purple there's a color purple curse you
know but it but but at the end of the
day he's got six but that's not why
that's not why brady is my goal but i do
agree with you that it's not
insignificant i just can't start there
or in there but go ahead you you're
saying something you'll say no but
but winning but winning is a big part of
it all right so this is why michael
jordan
no in the finals
6-0 in the finals is more impressive
than five and four for magic johnson
okay
now i mean you go and you don't lose
that's one
but you go six times you're a six-time
finals mvp
and
against some of the greatest players in
the history of the game carl was like
number nine
number two number two score in nba
history somewhere in there did not deny
them did not deny the leads
charles barkley stop yeah
dare you be compared to me i'm a shrug
magic right
magic you know so uh
that's a big that's a big deal now maybe
it's not uh 100
on the but it's like 75.
it's like 75 on the 100 point scale
that's a
that is probably the most impressive
modern
final stat and the only one that's
better so is okay bill russell from a
different era okay right so okay so okay
buy that rationale let's unpack this
let's continue let's continue down this
rabbit hole
lebron
both wins and he's finals mvp again so
he will be a four-time mvp four-time
runner-up in the regular season
he will be a
if he wins presumably he'll be finals
mvp he'll be a four-time finals mvp
correct with four championships
all right
and
we'll have
all of his losses whether it was to san
antonio
or
um
you know twice to go was it two or three
three times in golden state
right three times to go to state um
and then
no it's twice san antonio there's san
antonio in cleveland worst team ever
nobody we're seeing to go to the finals
nobody holds that against him the only
one that's actually changed chris forgot
about that team
he forgot about that the only one that's
actually held against him is dallas
because because he melted down against
the mavericks that's the only one that's
actually right held against fourth
quarter
not even so much anymore not even so
much but you look at the losses in the
finals most people don't put that at the
feet of the king the one except for
dallas so if he's four-time finals mvp
with four championships
four and six in the finals that would be
that's his resume if the lakers handle
business the way you think they will
you're telling me that that
in his totality with everything else
that lebron has done would you
immediately in a week vault him ahead of
michael jordan who just made the case
for his 6-0 with six finals mvps
it's considered it is not off the table
yeah i'm not in that position i know
some people are like that like well
forget it like jordan it can't you can't
challenge the throne and that's that's
been me that is so particularly that's
been me that's been are you like that
are you like that now are you still like
that
no i've said i've said several times
thanks for listening i've said it
several times since this show started
that
that i didn't account for the lebron
still being a lot going on i got a lot
going on man come on come on guys no i
got you no but like i didn't account for
lebron being this good this long so
um
i'm i feel like i'm still there but but
again sorry not lebron but jordan's six
championships is not the thing that i'm
holding on to it's the player it's the
player the all-around player which i
maintain gets lost in the debate the
all-around player that michael jordan
was gets
don't let this trigger you underrated
whether it's on a defensive end as a
passer
as a comp as the greatest post player
of all time better post moves than
anybody sorry i came elijah wanted
give me michael jordan's post move um
you
know i still think i'm i'm i'm there
but i was so listen man my boy pointed
out to me the other day
he said that once upon a time
if we if we're really kind of like you
know
opening up the vault here and talking
about uh talking about tapes there was a
time
and it was i'm trying to think of when i
was to prove to you that i can change my
mind to prove you that i can't change my
mind i'm not stubborn
there was a time
when i still had larry bird as my
starting three
like and i i i was you couldn't tell me
any different and lebron had won i think
a couple of championships by then
lebron had won titles and you can tell
me that the baddest man on the planet in
a league that had magic and isaiah
thomas the baddest man on the planet at
one time was larry bird playing
basketball
he was the guy he was he was i was like
that's my all time starting forward and
then lebron doing chase down blocks in
game seven and spreading his wings and
whatnot i'm like damn
so
i you know i think i'm a hold on to
jordan but if he keeps just doing
unbelievable things into his late 30s
and adding championship that's what
championships do start to come in it's
like well damn i mean like how do you
deny it so i don't you know that that's
why that was honestly michael
that was the inspiration behind
the the stuff i said the other day when
i was like part of it is not just trying
i'm not trying to settle the goat debate
or end the go debate for all of us i'm
trying to make peace with it within my
own mind i'm trying to say you know what
jordan's the best i ever saw and in my
mind the best to ever do it but there
are so many people
that will bring up kobe
and he's a different kind of goat maybe
you know i do think he's in the
conversation and that's honestly where
it ends for me with kobe rest in peace
but there are people that will bring up
kobe there are people that will say it's
still magic johnson bill russell with 11
championships kareem abdul-jabbar
wilt chamberlain now i'm just saying
names of people that's on that's in this
room and at this they got a seat at this
table they got a big long last supper
type table
yeah and if you ask me michael jordan's
sitting in the middle
michael jordan got jesus's seat i hope
that's not taking the lord's name in
vain but you understand what i'm going
with this visual here okay no he got
michael jordan's in the middle he got
the seat you said he got to see him yeah
he's saying it was jesus okay cool and
at this table you know you got wilt you
got magic you got larry you got kareem
you know you got kobe
you got two duncan
who's the jew who's judas who's judas
who's judas
don't do this
no but so
but but i'm trying but the reason i
brought up the stevie versus prince
you know michael versus lebron thing is
just like that's the best way i can
come to appreciate it without subjecting
it to a debate
all right i'll say two quick things here
two quick things one on the on the larry
boy larry
which is a great
larry bird point that's a really good
one
mike and you you're right he had that he
had that thing for a while in the 80s so
three straight mvps and and i know a lot
of people uh of a certain age when i say
90s or 80s what did i say did i say 90s
80s what did i say did i say 90s
i don't even think you said a year but
i'm just saying in the 80s
like three straight years
is mvp and i know a lot of people of a
certain age look at the 80s as the
golden era of basketball so in a league
that had doc and a league yep dr j
dr j right i know you mentioned
dr j
and kareem and magic and isaiah
larry bird holding down three straight
championships
but what's so difficult for some people
is to look at that because it's a
different style of basketball like larry
bird as nice as he was from range
larry bird didn't shoot trees
i mean i like that
when he came into the league they didn't
have threes did they
and that wasn't disappointment i think
the most threes he shot in the season
fourth season think about this yeah like
200.
like james james harden said i can do
that in 15 games you know what did you
get three points should come in what did
the three-point line come in it might
have been right it came in it wasn't a
part
yeah it was like eight uh 80 81
okay so yeah but two
yeah yeah the aba had it but it wasn't
it wasn't the game wasn't built around
threes but we know that larry bird was
one of the best shooters of all time
yeah he was nice with it he was nice but
that wasn't part of his game
so it came in at 79. his revenue okay
along with uh along with magic okay so
that's one but but here here's the other
thing about lebron that's really scary
and this is why i am open the the debate
door is wide open a real debate
okay
it is wide open
lebron's getting better
lebron is getting better like some of
the things some of the things you said
some of the things we said about lebron
in 2011 can you imagine
in 2020 saying
hey in the fourth quarter lebron kind of
shies away no
nobody says that so he had been in his
at that point that was his second finals
appearance
when they when they lost to the
mavericks so the second time in the
finals
people were two of ten people were
saying hey he kind of shrinks in the
fourth quarter you don't say that now
it's foolish to say that about lebron
james he's not slowing down
nobody is catching up with him nobody is
really you don't look at somebody and
say oh that guy is better than lebron
james how long is he how long he's not
he's not at the height of his athletic
prowess
but he's not he's not the same but he's
i'm like he's not the same guy
physically very very close but so much
smarter he just had the best fourth
quarter
of a close-out game that he's ever had
watch out man and he's in the
conversation
35.